he's Gordon Hayward the Boston Celtics
forward guard he joins us on behalf of
Dick's Sporting Goods and we'll have
more on that coming up more your phone
calls as well so we welcome in the
Celtic star Gordon Hayward and I'm sure
you're probably tired of talking about
your broken ankle and the injury and the
recovery so I'll ask you what would you
like to talk about today I guess we
could talk about getting ready for
Christmas at at my house we have two
little girls and so they're there
they're pretty excited okay who's your
wife's got to pick up the slack for you
doesn't she yeah she definitely
definitely does she's got a little
winter wonderland crazy in our house
with all the decorations but if she says
it's where the girls I think it's
secretly for herself to look at do you
have a favorite football team the cold
oh okay
and tough year down there yeah tough
here did you ever meet Andrew Luck no
but you did you play over in Europe or
something right yeah yeah he's doing
some treatment over I don't know what
they're doing over there in Europe did
you think of getting treatment over
there for your injury we haven't talked
about going over there right now I'm
progressing so well that they kind of
feel like we don't need to explore some
of those options where did you expect to
be with this recovery at this time you
know what I really didn't have too many
expectations like I've never this is the
first injury that I've had that's been
like like serious and so I've never had
to go through something like this and
honestly have kind of just taken it you
know day-by-day and week-by-week like
that's cliche is that sounds like that's
really how it's been for me and I
haven't they haven't put any
expectations on on me I haven't really
put any on myself except for you know
just to go in and
this week the rehab and you know try to
increase my range of motion each day and
you know do different things that I
wasn't able to do a week ago so I really
haven't expected anything what was worse
the pain or the depression definitely
the depression the pain is was I mean
it's been painful but it's it's nothing
like you know sitting sitting around
watching you know the team you were
supposed to be playing with this year
you know I to play for the Boston
Celtics this year only to now sit and
watch the Boston Celtics play all year
so it's that part is definitely
difficult and by far the much much
harder than are much more difficult to
deal with in the tone anybody who goes
through these type of injuries and your
competitor your professional being paid
you like to have that carrot that's
dangled like you almost have to use it
as inspiration as motivation that I'm
gonna get back I'm gonna try to get back
but how realistic is it that that is a
possibility for you or is that just the
mindset of I'm going to prepare to be
able to play again this year yeah I mean
like I said I work out every day to try
to increase my range of motion and
increase my strength in my legs so that
I can be back as fast as I can
and whether that's this year whether
that's you know this summer whether
that's next year I kind of just will let
that happen but you know for sure as a
competitor I'm trying to come back you
know faster than anyone else has done it
it's just one of those things where you
don't want to push it and you know maybe
hurt something else because you've been
off for so long or they keep me sticking
to a pretty strict protocol so that's
what I do
what did you tell your daughters when it
happened or your wife tell them yeah
well they're both like super young
they're but one of them is two and a
half the other ones one and a half okay
they don't understand they don't
understand too much what's going on they
just they saw that daddy had a boo-boo
so they'll run up to it and give it a go
give it a kiss initially I had a big
task and so they were decorating it with
stickers and drawing on the little day
you know they really added to them gave
me some perspective because they just
they they're happy that I'm all more
than anything they don't they don't
realize what's going on
is it cathartic to talk about this I
mean does it does it help you to talk
about this Georgia is it I don't know I
you know some people don't want to talk
about it or have you seen the video or
you just that happened I have to move I
don't want to be reminded of it it's one
of the things where I think talking
about I actually I'm seeing a sports
psychologist once a week and you know we
talked about the injury and then talk
about moving forward and you know talk
about some of the positives that can
come from it I think if you continually
like to watch the tape or talk about it
and then just dwell on that and dwell on
the negatives that can really you know
spiral into it like a deep depression
but you know talking about it and
talking about how you know I'm able to
work on things that I might not be able
to do if I was in the middle of season
just with the workloads and playing a
lot of meds like spinning it a different
way so you can look at the positives
it's something that I've been trying to
work on and so for me I'm kind of out of
that out of that depression phase he's
Gordon Hayward the Celtics card joining
us Dan Patrick show how many times you
looked at the video I've seen it once
all the way through and I've seen like
parts of it he were there just like
watching watching on the TV but I've
only seen him once all the way through
body go into shock
yeah it definitely does I still remember
the play like it was just yesterday and
kind of looking down at my ankle and
seeing it in the complete wrong
direction and I'll probably always
remember that part but you know it's one
of those things Rita you feeling like I
start to think about it and just don't
realize that it that it really
happened you know I don't know if your
therapist talks about this debt you know
do you do make sure you don't change
your game like you you still have to go
out and play the way you normally play
to become this all-star and you know
this free agent that the Celtics sign
right ya know that that's 100% true and
you know the play that we ran there I'd
done that play probably 60 70 times last
year and so I think you know what I'll
be a hundred percent is when I'm able to
mentally run that same play again and
not even think twice and I think that's
you know that's another hurdle at the
end where you might be physically I
could be physically 100 percent but I
still I'm gonna have to you know get
past the mental part of it as well
we spent a lot of time yesterday talking
about Kobe Bryant didn't know if you had
a favorite Kobe Bryant story for us well
for me it was it was his last game cuz I
was directly involved with it um we were
there I got a full you know front-row
seat to that 60 point game and I don't
think I'll ever play in a game with that
type of atmosphere where it seemed like
every time he got the ball the whole
crowd was chanting for him to score and
if you played defense people were
getting mad at you interesting game a
cool experience
you know nonetheless and like I said it
that's that's probably my favorite one
how many did you score on you though
Gordon I don't know I know that he
scored 60 on us altogether so there was
probably quite a few on me I think it's
a pretty cool thing that you're you have
the number one best selling Celtics
jersey at Dick's Sporting Goods
explained that yeah how did that happen
yeah no it is cool and Dick's has a
jersey report exporting this as a jury's
a report that they update daily and I
think it is it is pretty cool that you
know you can go on and see you know
exactly what what players have you know
the most Jersey sales and from his it's
a probably a lot of it would be just
because I moved over to the Celtics and
you know Boston is huge passionate
sports fan base
but still I think pretty cool that you
know I'm not even playing and they're
still supporting me so it's awesome well
good luck in the recovery and you know
what you'll look back and say you got a
chance to spend a whole lot of time at
home certainly with your daughters and
you know if that's the reward out of it
still pretty good reward that's right
thank you Thank You Gordon for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]